pour villepreux commune de 11000 151
habitants cinq candidats sont en lice
pour les municipales 2020 kourosh gold
gold chirurgien spécialiste en orl
habite à villepreux depuis 2002 à titre
personnel il est adhérent les
républicains parmi les projets défendus
par sa liste divers droite la création
d'une maison de santé développer un
centre de garde qui serait qui sera
ouvert de 8 heures du matin jusqu'à
minuit avec un minimum par exemple
radiologie auch depuis bonnaire et qu'on
fasse le tri et le traitement des gens
sur place
c'est un service aux personnes âgées et
aux personnes en situation de handicap
aux enfants c'est primordial
merde villepreux depuis 2008 stéphane
mirambeau et candidat pour un troisième
mandat cadres supérieurs du secteur
privé il est également le quatrième
vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge du
budget l'un des projets du candidat la
redynamisation du centre ville
on va pouvoir mettre des animations à
pouvoir mettre des marchés on va
redonner de la vie et on va pouvoir dans
une autre zone de ce même endroit
pouvoir tester des choses c'est un tiers
lieu il ya beaucoup de gens de ce
village qui nous disent vous ne pensez
plus à nous il n'ya plus de commerces
y a pas de commerce car n'y avait pas de
parking tête de liste d'agir avec vous
pour ville preuve valérie bain et
directrice d pad habite à villepreux
depuis 20 ans est adhérente à titre
personnel à la république en marche
parmi les projets mis en avant par cette
liste le développement de la culture
nous avons un théâtre de 600 places qui
ne fonctionne plus depuis douze ans et
donc on voudrait au moins qui servent
aux associations et aux différents
groupes artistiques et serra qui sont
obligés de se produire à l'extérieur où
trouver des salles à l'extérieur
désormais conseillère municipale
d'opposition sylvie ce vent montait les
têtes de liste de tous pour villepreux
collaboratrice parlementaire elle est
également conseillère communautaire
déléguée à l'école innovantes
les enfants sont font partie russe pour
prendre partie de notre coeur de notre
programme
on va leur réserver une parcelle dans
les jardins potagers pour eux pour que
les centres de loisirs et les écoles
puissent avoir leur périmètre
mon objectif c'est que le foyer du
théâtre l'entrée du théâtre il ya un bel
espace en dehors de représentation sap
est un espace utilisé pour la jeunesse
ville président depuis 1996 jean
baptiste
monique et chef de cabinet parlementaire
il est également délégué départemental
et porte-parole du modem dans les
yvelines la lys villepreux naturellement
a fait part mi a fait de ses priorités
l'environnement et la défense du cadre
de vie de notre biodiversité
je pense notamment un objectif de zéro
artificialisation des sols que nous
inscrirons op élus afin que nous sans
que tu as raison nos espaces naturels et
puis nous voudront pousser la transition
écologique local de plus en plus au fur
et à mesure que les années passent on